What's up wisecrack Jared here during these highly unstable times.
One of the few things we can know for certain is that you have recently seen
tiger King.
Another certainty is that you can't stop thinking about Joe exotics music
videos.
This Netflix show about feuding owners of Genki zoos has dominated our brain
space,
consumed our weekly all-staff meetings and even resulted in the occasional
Carole Baskin theme. Nightmare. The show is addicting,
baffling and far jucier than any expired.
Wal-Mart meet much of the media attention surrounding tiger King has
appropriately focused on Joe exotic, the endlessly fascinating gun,
toting polyamorous redneck. Now incarcerated big cat owner.
Unsurprisingly he's become something of a cultural icon in his own, right?
Similarly,
his fellow big cat dealer doc Antle has claimed that he's received a wild influx
of male and female applicants eager to join his sprawling harem of
scantily clad tiger trainers. Keep in mind,
these folks live and labor in squalor earn somewhere between $0 and way less
than minimum wage and still behave like they have the best job in the world.
I'm doing tiger shows.
And while I certainly understand the appeal of becoming besties with a cat that
might murder me, I still have so many questions. Like what, why,
how luckily one of our other side obsessions can answer the question of what
makes someone like Joe exotic or doc Antle so addicting to Netflix audiences
and wayward teenagers alike, specifically Colts.
Now the word Colt might stir images of barefoot Manson chicks rather than pro
bono tiger trainers.
But even if the subjects of tiger King are not running full fledged Colts,
the psychology of cults can do a whole lot to explain how perfectly ordinary
people become unflinchingly,
loyal to a guy with a soul patch or someone who changed their last name to
exotic and above all it poses. The question. Could you, dear viewer,
even wind up training tigers for $0 an hour after all,
are we not all susceptible to cult-like behaviors?
Let's find out in this wisecrack edition on tiger King as always spoilers ahead
for the most bananas TV show you've seen since going into quarantine,
but before we get into it, I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsor foot mouse.
Science-based gaming mouse made for feet. It's just such a huge advantage,
but it's still all about skill, but malice just raises the stakes.
Okay? Yeah. We're not serious.
This video is actually sponsored by raid shadow legends.
For those of you that don't know raid shadow legends is a free hero collector
RPG available on mobile and PC. You can level up your champions,
fight Epic boss battles and challenge other players in PVP battles.
If you haven't played it yet, now is the perfect time to start.
Their new player rewards program just got extended from 90 to 180 days.
For the first hundred 80 days, you log in,
you will be rewarded with energy refills, gems, silver,
and even Epic champion sill of the Drake.
Click the link in the description to download the game today,
use our within the next 30 days, and you'll get a hundred thousand silver,
50 gems and energy refill, and a free Epic champion. The executioner,
all this treasure will be waiting for you here.
The rewards will be available only for new players. And now back to the show,
if you submit how haven't seen it,
tiger King immerses us in the very weird world of big cat owners.
Primarily Joe exotic,
a Kansas man come Oklahoma and who operates a small zoo for lions,
tigers and other animals that definitely don't belong in cages. The narrative,
which becomes exponentially more bonkers by the minute details,
a growing feud between Joe and Carol Baskin,
a devoted lover of animal prints who operates big cat rescue,
a sanctuary apparently dedicated to ending the selling breeding and commercial
cuddling of this adorable tiger Cub.
The feud escalates to the point where send your exotic,
apparently hire someone to murder Carol,
and act that combined with his big cat industrial complex,
lands him over two decades in prison,
along the way he acquires three young male husbands,
one of whom dies tragically. Oh, and also Carol's millionaire.
Second husband vanishes into thin air.
Also Joe runs the world's weirdest presidential camp.
And this is all paid for by the committee of Joe exotic speaks for America.
Okay.
Carol runs the world's weirdest Facebook live stream. And again,
doc runs a literal harem. Also the music videos,
so many music videos, some of which honestly,
and please don't roast me for this, or maybe not that bad.
Most of the tiger King cultural discourse has dealt with me modifying Joe exotic
and the other cast of absurd characters. What we found most interesting though,
wasn't Joe's political aspirations or even Carol's potentially murder his
streak. Rather we're finding ourselves obsessed with the way two of the central
characters,
Joe exotic and doc Antle build and maintain their avid followings of low to
no paid workers and fans. That is to say,
how did these two borderline lunatics effectively become kind of cult-y
before we can prove that Joe exotic is actually Oklahoma's finest cultist to
ever Colt.
We need to look at what defines a cult in the first place as is the case with
most complicated and fascinating things.
The definition of the word cult is notoriously slippery,
which is why people have written entire academic papers.
Debating said definition in summation for a long time.
The word cult was relatively neutral term associated with conventional religious
or spiritual groups, such as a cult of a Roman God. In the 19th century,
the word began to develop a pejorative street being used to describe excessive
devotion. As cults became more common in the seventies.
Anti-culture river also Rose and cultural fascination surrounding cult has
remained strong sense for ease of understanding.
We're going to define Colts by their common characteristics as defined by
psychiatrist and Harvard professor Robert J Lifton in his paper,
cult formation in it.
He delineated the three central characteristics of a destructive cult.
These were one a leader to coercive persuasion or
thought reform.
I E brainwashing and three economic sexual and other exploitation of
group members by the leader and their inner circle.
We'd argue that the organizations have Joe exotic and doc Antle both exhibit
some level of these three.
Characteristics. He's got his little coat and I got my letter.
When it comes to number one charismatic leaders,
tiger King does not disappoint most notably. Of course we have Joe exotic,
a dude with enough red neck charm to convince not one but two apparently
straight men,
young enough to be his son to enter a three-way marriage with him and his
glorious Mowat cult leaders,
whether they're Charles Manson or a Kool-Aid slurping,
Jim Jones demand to be the center of attention.
Joe exotic marketed his zoo as his own personal stage.
He thrived on being filmed,
even when said filming was of intensely incriminating acts like threatening
murder, Colt leaders,
demand adoration and through a mix of charisma self-confidence and seductive
tendencies inspire and almost pathological devotion in their followers.
It's not surprising that they often take on vaguely religious monikers from
Nixon leader, Keith Raniere, who went by Vanguard to the source family leader,
father yod.
It's not just about picking a super cool and not lame at all name like Joe
exotic or Bhagavan.
Nope. Bhagavan means that you're a friend of God.
According to psychotherapists, Daniel Shaw claimed their power.
Vis-a-vis their traumatic narcissism,
which he explains as a version of self-centeredness and self-aggrandizing far
more sinister than anything you could accuse your typical imagine singing
celebrity of for Shaw traumatic narcissism can be summarized as the
objectification of one person in a relationship as the means of enforcing the
dominance of the subjectivity of the other. That is to say,
when you become involved with a traumatically narcissistic person,
you surrender the right to have your own mind and perspective.
You internalize the narcissists doctrine and worldview and learn to dread
thinking for yourself.
That just about sums up a lot of the relationships we see in tiger King with
both Joe exotic and doc Antle effectively acting as preachers of the sacred
gospel of the tiger.
They happily use their charisma and sexual power to take advantage of vulnerable
people under the guise of saving these admittedly amazing animals as all
traumatizing narcissists do doc and Joe think that their emotional needs Trump.
All others maybe asked me what's wrong, but he only spends five seconds. Listen,
and then he'll walk away.
This brings us to point number two, coercive persuasion or thought reform.
This point is a little complicated because for the most part,
we don't really see the indoctrination process.
As the followers seem pretty acclimated to hashtag Colt life.
By the time we meet them.
But we do see the implications of that indoctrination in the way Joe and doc
expect their employees to sacrifice everything in order to work toward their
designated goal.
Whether that goal is actually saving tigers or merely improving their
downtrodden menagerie is, is almost beside the point.
Arguably the best evidence of Joe exotic and doc Antle exquisite hold over their
followers comes in a few specific moments.
First doc makes his inner circle all changed their names as if to divorce
themselves from their prior identities. A common tactic in Colts.
China came right after I came.
Her name was Michelle Moshe was named Meredith
Rodney. When I met her, her name was Renee.
I had my name legally changed to Bala for many years,
changing your name. It's a very quick way to change everything else about.
Then there's when Joe's employee loses an arm and rather than electing to spend
two years getting reconstructive surgery instead gets it amputated and goes back
to work after five days.
So it was not to hurt the collective cause of saving tigers.
Now here's where things get a little complicated because lots of non culty
people make sacrifices for the greater good think of a protestor,
putting themselves in front of a tank or a healthcare worker putting themselves
in harm's way to help their patients. But there's a pretty important difference.
That is the huge discrepancy in who is benefiting from your sacrifice. Sure,
the tigers, but most importantly, Joe and his bank account.
Never going to financially recover from.
This. And this kind of logic will inform a lot more than just cults,
but we'll get there. Similarly,
doc Antle expects the 24 seven work efforts of those unfortunate enough to be in
his harem. Unless of course they're recovering from a boob job.
He coerced them into.
They were pushing me to get implants, but.
They get away with this. It all comes down to the demographic.
Cult leaders seek out. Typically people who joined Colts are young isolated,
and in transitory moments of their life.
I am tall tan.
In fact, psychiatrist, John G.
Clark Jr notes that cult leaders will frequent bus stations, airports, campuses,
libraries, rallies,
anywhere that unattached persons are likely to be passing through and act.
We literally see Joe doing when he recruits this woman into his tiger coat in
her onscreen interview, Barbara Fisher notes,
that doc Antle tended to go for women who were virgins that is uninitiated into
the world of sexual relationships,
rendering them far more likely to fall into it.
His orbit, there was a certain personality of woman that he wanted.
They were virgins or close to Virgin.
Leaders.
As traumatic narcissists are notoriously mercurial using their endlessly
vacillating emotions to confuse disorient and manipulate their followers.
We see this with Joe who's narcissism seems only to be augmented when he's on
camera. Sometimes he'll be kind and inspiring.
Sometimes he'll lash out cruelly at his employees,
even firing them purely to generate drama like a real housewife on
steroids.
Yeah, the slacker and do less than anybody here. Ain't gonna work with me.
So you need to find a new job.
Then there's the third criteria,
exploitation of one's followers in economic sexual, and other resorted arenas.
This most commonly occurs when Colt leaders overwork their followers in the
Colts family business, whether that means dumpster diving for food,
like a Manson girl or helping to run the multi-level marketing cult, Nexium,
or working as housekeeper for the lesser known divine.
This is doc and Joe to a T.
Yeah, but I just work all day. But I'm of like,
it's like a stay home to midnight, 8:00 AM to midnight.
You're working every day.
Yeah. Typically, and as we see in tiger King,
these work days are long and grueling,
leaving followers too exhausted to do anything,
but go to sleep and dream about their beloved leaders.
This state of overwork puts their followers in a chronic state of sensory
deprivation, which makes them easier to manipulate and control.
Arguably spending 12 hours a day, seven days a week,
shoveling tiger poo and manicuring tiger lawns makes you more pliable,
more obedient.
And some cult experts would say can even potentially alter your brain chemistry
on the economic exploitation front. All of these people may close to.
How much do people get paid a hundred dollars?
Are we enriching their leaders, but also inhibiting their ability to leave.
Then of course, there's the sex stuff.
Joe and doc seemed to exclusively prey on young people who lack solidified
sexual identities and in Joe's case,
even potentially using drugs to coerce them into sex.
When you have a charismatic leader who has separated you from the outside world
and forces you to work hard for almost $0,
can you really be in a willing and healthy sexual relationship? We say, nah,
and most shrinks would probably back us up on this.
So with these three sucky criteria fulfilled,
we're left with one big looming question.
How do these leaders convince their members to stay?
That's where we get to the real nucleus of what makes a cold.
And if it weren't so sad and potentially lethal, it could be kind of beautiful.
Human beings are almost genetically engineered to seek a purpose in life for
centuries. That purpose was primarily realized in mainstream religion,
likely a big reason that cult spring up with such force in 1970s,
America was the downturn of mainstream religiosity that followed the baby boomer
hippie awakening of the sixties.
When you lose weekly church sermons about God's love, you need a replacement.
Thousands of Americans found that replacement in Colts,
whether it was the Manson family, Scientology, children of God or so on.
Each of these groups featured a charismatic leader who offered critically a
purpose to their followers for the Manson family.
That purpose was free love with a side of race war for Scientology.
It was advancing through bogus classes until you could learn even more bogus
secrets of the universe.
He'd say the fifth invaders are up there and this is how they addressed.
This is how they.
For the heaven's gate cult.
It was the promise of transcendence into an extraterrestrial spacecraft for Jim
Jones's unfortunate followers.
It was the doctrine of so-called revolutionary suicide.
And if you're a tiger trainer at the ritzy Myrtle beach Safari,
or the jenky GW zoo,
you are following the gospel of saving the tigers as noble as that goal may
actually be.
And Joe exotic especially makes a borderline convincing case for that goal in
the early episodes of the show,
expressing a genuine desire to save big cats from extinction via shopping mall,
cuddling sessions, achieving a higher purpose is lovely.
We wish it for all of you, but please God,
not at the expense of your favorite arm.
Of course we haven't really dealt with Carol basket and who is almost certainly
not a cult leader that said she does exhibit a culty characteristic here and
there most notably unexpecting her volunteers to work long grueling hours for $0
in devotion to her car.
I don't pay anybody to do animal care because people will do that for free.
So her whole uniform thing is pretty much textbook Colt material.
Volunteers wear a color coded shirt system after they've been here for like five
years or so, they can graduate to a master keeper and that's blue.
That's a Navy blue there's Royal blue.
You can find an exact analogy in Nexium,
which ranked its member status by colored sashes.
Obviously being stoked about your uniform doesn't mean you're in a cult,
but the members' devotion to a rigid hierarchy as decreed by Carol indicates a
certain subservience to her mission.
Of course it's worth asking aren't some of these tactics say of bullying people
into changing their behavior employed in say your local CrossFit class,
aren't you basically paying to work for your local improv theater or go over
$500 for an advanced class that includes performing for paying audiences.
What about multi-level marketing schemes that extensively offer you meaning and
economic emancipation so long as you're willing to buy $20,000 worth of tie dyed
leggings,
we'd argued that the incessant human quest for meaning is capable of being
exploited by any charismatic leader in almost every area of human life.
Even that of certain YouTube celebs though, we certainly won't name names,
whether we're prostrating ourselves to the SoulCycle instructor or dedicating
our lives to climbing up the ranks of a multi-level vitamin company,
we're all guilty of subsuming our independence and the name of a common goal.
Often while being marshaled by the words of a seductive leader,
even if our life isn't being run by a traumatic narcissist,
we're all capable of being whipped into cult-like frenzies.
And it's certainly not a bad thing to find a cause you believe in unless you
lose your autonomy.
There's a difference between volunteering for doctors without borders versus
moving to spawn ranch with Charles Manson. But you know,
if a guy with a mullet offers you a trailer to live in,
in exchange for a lifetime of servitude,
maybe just try to find meaning in your local fantasy football league instead
hell I'd even recommend soul cycle. But what do you think wisecrack,
are we reading too much into the gospel of Joe exotic and doc Antle or are they
fully 100% Colt material? And is the search for meaning inherent in all of us,
a big part of what makes tiger King so addictive,
let us know which thing in the comments,
a huge thanks to our patrons for supporting the channel and our podcast hit that
subscribe button. And as always, thanks for watching guys.
Peace.